each year five million Americans get
their wisdom teeth removed which costs
about three billion dollars in total
medical costs but for many it's worth it
since leaving them in can cause serious
problems like gum infection tooth decay
and even tumors but wisdom teeth weren't
always the unwelcome threat we see today
[Music]
wisdom teeth have been around for
millennia our ancient ancestors used
them the same way we use our other eight
molars to grind up food which was
especially handy before the advent of
cooking around 7,000 years ago back when
our diet consisted of raw meat and
plants that were fibrous and tough to
chew but once we got our hands on softer
cooked foods our powerful jaws no longer
needed to work as hard and shrank as a
result but here's the problem the genes
that determine the size of our jaws are
completely separate from the genes that
determine how many teeth we grow so as
our jaws shrank we still kept all 32
teeth and it eventually got to the point
where there wasn't enough space to fit
all of the teeth but why did wisdom
teeth specifically get the boot well
they're at the last to show up to the
party wisdom teeth don't usually grow in
until you're between 16 and 18 years old
and by that time chances are your other
28 teeth have taken up all the available
space in your mouth in that case instead
of growing in like a normal tooth wisdom
teeth get trapped or impacted in your
jaw which often makes them grow in at
odd angles and press against your back
molars causing pain and swelling it also
forms a narrow crevice between the teeth
creating the perfect food trap
this makes the tooth difficult to clean
which attracts more bacteria and can
cause infection and tooth decay
eventually leading to gum disease if
left untreated but it gets worse tooth
decay can eventually destroy your wisdom
tooth so to save you and your teeth from
such a horrible fate
this will often remove wisdom teeth
before they go rogue seems reasonable
right well it's actually a controversial
topic among some in the dental community
the worry is that we're removing our
wisdom teeth too frequently often when
it's unnecessary and the teeth pose no
threat like if your mouth is big enough
or you're one of the 38% of people who
don't develop all four wisdom teeth in
that case risks from surgery like
infection and nerve damage pose more
danger than the teeth themselves but the
fact remains when wisdom teeth do become
a problem you'll curse the day we
invented cooking
[Music]